I want to just quickly go through some
of the interesting discussions on our
reddit discussion forum this is the best
place for david pakman show viewers and
listeners to talk with each other
suggests stories talk to me i check it
mostly every day i'm in the comments
there and there's a lot of really really
good discussions you can access the
reddit discussion forum by going to
david pakman.com slash reddit that's our
EDD IT let's take a look at some of the
stories sometimes it's show related
stuff we'll start with one example here
volume of the show am I the only one
that thinks that the overall level of
the show has gotten lower uh that's an
issue were working on right i mean pat
you and I have been working on that
sometimes it's hard to know because
there's the volumes of our mics relative
to each other and then they're sort of
like the total volume of the show
relative to other shows people might
listen to and since we've been making
changes in upgrades this is what we call
a work in progress but suffice it to say
people should know we're on this issue
yeah you're exactly right and I'm new at
this too but I think it's getting better
I think we're almost we almost have it
down we have it almost down and today
there will be a slight increase to the
volume of the show so know that we are
paying attention to the comments on
reddit now here's an interesting post
about Dilbert cartoonist Scott Adams and
his thought about Donald Trump there's
an article on Slate about Scott Adams
I've been a huge fan of Dilbert for a
very very very long time but i have to
tell you some of scott adams is recent I
don't want to call it gushing about
Donald Trump but some of his recent
comments about Donald Trump I'm not
particularly thrilled with here's
another discussion from reddit about
arguing with people on the internet
someone pointing out that when people
use the term I only use proven facts to
make my points that it is often just not
true and that people very very
frequently don't even really know the
definition of what facts are and that
caused a really interesting discussion
on our reddit discussion forum and then
lastly are very interesting thread about
the election Vladimir Putin and World
War 3 and this got a number of calm
and a very very interesting conversation
going so please join us on reddit I'm on
there you can talk to me you can talk to
other viewers there are some trolls like
with most Internet discussion platforms
who also frequent the david pakman show
read it but they're pretty easily
ignored so don't worry about it you can
go to david pakman.com slash read it
that is re d di t